Welcome back.
These are the days where I literally come into work
pinching myself thinking that I am in the dream job
of all dream jobs, because our next guest,
well, there's just nothing that he can't do.
He's an actor, an author,
a 16 time winning WWE World Champion.
He's adding superhero to his resume of esteemed acting.
I think he's an incredible comedian as well.
And his new HBO max show, the "Peacemaker" is about to drop,
take a look.
Why are you in your costume?
(chuckles)
Costume? This is a uniform and it's brand new.
So I gotta stretch it out make me more comfortable
before going to mission.
Maybe I'm stupid, but why would you even wanna wear that
on a mission?
A bright red shirt and white pants
aren't exactly conducive to lurking in the shadows.
People see this uniform, strikes fear in their hearts.
What people, the other people
at the village people trials.
(laughs)
(applause)
Please welcome everybody's favorite,
the very talented John Cena
(upbeat music)
(crowed cheers)
Finally this moment has happened.
(indistict)
Its a pleasure to meet you.
Thank you so much for having me.
Thank you guys, thank you.
(crowed cheers)
Can we sit, can we talk, can we sit and talk?
I would love to sit and talk,
thank you for everything that you do.
I always thought when I was a kid,
I looked at other people in the same job force
that I was in.
And I always admired the ones where I'm like,
I don't know if they're dramatic,
I don't know if they're a comedian,
I don't know if they're this or they're that.
Every person that I admire most
taught me to have range.
And that range was one of the greatest art forms
that we could have,
'cause you never really knew where someone was coming from,
which was not only exciting,
but meant that they could diversify their portfolio.
And that is you to a tee.
(sighs)
Too kind.
It's true.
Thank you very much.
She's way, way too kind so thank you.
(applause)
That's very nice of you to say
I'm still very much in the learning process of all this,
but a lot of the comedy,
especially with me being a big lumbering individual
is not taking myself too seriously.
And being able to laugh at myself,
coming on a television show dressed as peacemaker,
my stylist has, she fired me.
(all laughs)
And she's my wife so trouble with the workplace.
But anyway, here I am dressed as a superhero
and we got a show out on HBO max,
and to say I'm not nervous as a bold face lie.
I am so glad you said that 'cause I'm nervous at work
all the time.
(applause)
Yeah, yeah but that okay,
I think if you get to that point where you're not nervous,
you talk to any athlete who takes a field before a game.
If they get to that point where they lose that edge,
even as a live performer,
man I've gone down that ramp way too many times.
(crowd laughs)
But every single time, there's that moment,
right before you pull the curtain back,
you just, it's a feeling, an indescribable feeling
of everything at peak insanity.
And then you go out and it's amazing
even when it's the long nights where you suck, it's amazing,
but there's not a night, there's not a time,
there's not a time that I've ever walked around that door
that I'm not nervous.
I don't think you...
I do think you know how valuable that is.
That's helping me right now because I'm scared in this job
all the time, I am.
I try to be a journalist,
I've never been a talk show host before,
I'm dealing with broadcast in a digital age.
There is everything that I'm trying to figure out
on the job sometimes and that just made me feel less alone.
I think you're doing great as a talk show host,
I think you're doing great as a journalist.
(applause)
That means so much to me coming form you,
you're such a good person.
(John laughs)
Now, I love the fact that you have had many jobs,
including being a groundskeeper at a golf course
and an ice cream scooper.
But one of my favorites is that you were a limo driver.
I was, so I was about 19.
This was pre GPS you still had to buy a map.
I grew up in the small town of West Newbury, Massachusetts,
Yep.
Just 1,500 people strong and it is one hour and 30 minutes
north of Boston.
I'd never been to the city in my entire life.
I was given a job driving Lincoln Town Cars
to and from Logan airport,
a place I'd never been to in my life.
(Drew laughs)
I also was 225 pounds by the time I was 19 years old
and I was training for a bodybuilding competition
at the time.
So I brought my food in the car,
my Lincoln Town Car smelled of steamed chicken breasts
and tuna fish.
(crowd laughs)
So I was always late and I mean, late,
I would pick people up two and a half hours late
for their flight.
Yeah.
(crowd laughs)
I earned every single expletive that I was called
and I gotta hand it to the passengers.
They came up with some new stuff I'd never even heard.
And I grew up with four brothers.
(crowd laughs)
All right so I love that
I read that you like doing interviews
because you think it gives you a chance
to let people in on you, is this true?
Well, there's a lot of reasons I like doing interviews.
First of all, it's part of the process.
Yes.
And we also have to get people interested
You can have the best performance in the world
if nobody knows about it, nobody's gonna go see it
and you can't do it again.
And you're making, what's called a home video.
(Drew laughs)
I want people to come see and a lot of that
is spreading the word,
letting people know "Peacemaker" is on HBO Max,
so you guys go and see it so I can be peacemaker again.
And that this is part of that.
Thank you very much one person, yeah.
Having seen it, you guys are gonna love it , its so good.
I am loving it so much, and we're actually gonna get into,
if you don't mind, I'd like to try and do some peacekeeping,
peace making with you.
We're gonna try make some peace right?
Yeah, we're gonna make some peace.
Yeah, totally not qualified.
Actually.
But am into it.
You now what? Let's do it right now.
Okay, cool.
All right, so we have a mom and a daughter
Eliana and, Ananziata and we were wondering
what your conflict is.
And John and I are gonna attempt,
he's gonna take the lead
And again.
I am totally not qualified.
This is just my personal opinion with no backing whatsoever,
but am gonna do my best.
I would love to ask what is your conflict?
(laughs)
So our little conflict, my mom and I are super close,
we've been really close ever since I was little and I'm 19.
So I'm in college now, I go to school in Missouri.
But the issue here is that my mom,
she's very Italian and she loves being part
of every little aspect of my life
and knowing all the details.
But as a adult now, I want some more privacy,
especially like in my dating life and things like that.
How do we navigate that kind of situation?
Yeah.
I heard your opinion, anything to add over there?
(laughs)
Anaziata, do you have something to say?
I just worry about anything and everything,
I don't know what's out there.
I just worry about anything and everything.
So I just want to make sure she's good and she's safe
and kinda wanna know what her daily life is like but-
First of all, in no way, shape or form,
am I a parent, but I am a child.
And I found my best connection with my parents
is transferring that parent child relationship
into a peer adult relationship.
And maybe it's time for you as a daughter
to begin approaching conversation to your mom
about adult subjects, or just the yearning to wanting
to be treated as an adult not a child.
And maybe it's time for you as a mom to think about,
as your daughter gets older, more educated,
wiser to the ways of the world.
How you wanna go about redefining your relationship.
So you don't look at her as a child and in capable child
when she's desiring freedom,
and maybe you both evolve in a way where you can grow
as mother and daughter together, but it's two adults.
Your adult relationship with your daughter
is gonna be a whole lot longer than the childhood one.
Right?
And for me personally, this didn't happen at 19.
That's when I was very rebellious to my parents
at that point, because I really thought they were...
They were just trying to protect me
but I thought they were trying to hold me back.
So when I see I've developed a strong relationship,
this is just fairly recently last decade or so.
So maybe just start planting the seeds now
for that foundation of your future relationship,
where you're two adults who can share the magic
of adult life.
(laughs)
Okay, is there another show that you and I
are supposed to be in together,
where we fully do relationships, human interest?
(applause)
I am having a blast.
Okay, well, let's go to commercial
and then just get right back into this conversation
If you don't mind.
We'll be right back everybody.
(applause)
(upbeat music)